the last video we constructed an
experiment where we had a drug that we
thought might help control people's
blood sugar we looked for something that
we could measure as an indicator for
their blood Sugar's being controlled and
hemoglobin a1c is actually what people
measure in a blood test it is we have a
whole video on it on Khan Academy but it
is a average measure of your blood sugar
over roughly at three-month period so
that's the explanatory variable whether
or not you're taking the pill and the
response variable is well what does it
do to your hemoglobin a1c and we
constructed a somewhat classic
experiment where we had a control group
and a treatment group and we randomly
assigned folks in to either the control
or the treatment group and to ensure
that one group or the other or I guess
both of them don't end up with an
imbalance of in the case in the case of
the last video an imbalance of men or
women we did what we call a block design
where we took our hundred people and we
just happen to have 60 women and 40 men
we said okay well let's split the 60
women randomly between the two groups
and let's split the 40 men between these
two groups so that we have at least an
even distribution with respect to sex
and so we would measure folks a1cs
before they get the treatment or the
placebo then we would wait three months
of getting either the treatment or the
placebo and then we'll see if there's a
statistically significant improvement
now this was a pretty good and it's a
bit of a classic experimental design we
would also do it so that the patients
don't know which one they're getting
placebo or the actual treatment so it's
a blind experiment and it's probably
good if even the nurses or the doctors
who are administering the pills we're
giving the pills also don't know which
one they're giving so it would be a
double-blind experiment but this doesn't
mean that it's a perfect experiment and
this seldom is a perfect experiment and
that's why it should be able to be
replicated other people should try to
prove the same thing it may be in
different ways but even the way that we
designed it there's still a possibility
that there are some lurking variables in
here maybe you know we we took we took
care to make sure that our distribution
of men and women was roughly even across
both of these groups but maybe by
through that random sampling we got a
disproportionate number of young people
in the treatment group
and maybe young people responded better
to taking a pill
maybe that you know that it changes
their behaviors in other ways or maybe
older people when they take a pill they
decide to eat worse because they say oh
this pill is going to solve all my
problems and so you could have these
other looking variables like age or
where in the country they live or other
types of things that just by the random
process might you might have things get
uneven in one way or another
now one technique to help control for
this a little bit and I shouldn't use
the word control too much another
technique to help mitigate this is
something called matched pairs design
matched matched pairs pairs design of an
experiment and it's essentially instead
of you know going through all of this
trouble saying oh boy maybe we do block
design all this random sampling instead
you randomly put people first into
either the control of the treatment
group and then we do another round you
measure and they do another round where
you switch where the people who are in
the treatment go to the control and the
people who are the control go into the
treatment so we could even extend from
what we have here we can imagine a world
where the first three months we we have
the 50 people in the this treatment
group we have another 50 people in this
control group that are taking the
placebo we see what happens to the a1cs
and then we switch where where this
group over here then and they don't know
they don't know first of all ideally
it's a blind experiment so they don't
even know they were in the treatment
groups and hopefully the pills look
identical so now that same group for the
next three months is now going to be the
control group and so they got the
medicine for the first three months and
we saw what happens to their a1c and now
they're going to get the placebo they
are going to get the placebo for the
second three months and then we are
going to see what happens to their a1c
and likewise the other group is going to
be switched around the thing that the
folks that used to be getting the
placebo could now get could now get the
treatment they are now going to get the
treatment
and the value here is is that because
everyone is going through but is that
for one period is in the control group
and for one period is in the treatment
group and they don't know when which one
is happening you are less likely to have
a lurking variable like age or
geographic region or behavior that cause
an imbalance or in some how skew the
results or give you biased results so
this is an interesting thing and and you
know even what I've talked about in this
video in the last one these are just
different ways to approach it and as you
construct experiments this is in
medicine you'll obviously construct
experiments in other fields it's
important to think about what types of
things are practical to do and also are
have the best chance at giving you real
I guess you say an unbiased and real
information as to in the case of an
experiment to the efficacy of something
or whether a certain variable an
explanatory variable really does a drive
have a have a causal effect on a
response variable